you know I can't help but find a
slightly ironic that I'm recording this
while recovering from a bug yeah you're
not getting the joke in the opening just
a bit of a factual observation cuz
that's kind of where I'm at right now so
this is a patreon commission review this
was something I had never heard of
before I was asked to review it and it
is a film called
recovery and it stars David Tennant he's
not the only like his involvement
I suspect was the reason that this was
commissioned for me because of his
connection to doctor and I did a lot of
Doctor Who stuff maybe not the person
who commissioned me didn't give me a lot
of details for their reasoning behind it
but I will say that if anything I say
about the set up of the premise before I
start really getting into it intrigued
you at all it is actually free to view
on YouTube and it's until it in its
entirety
I might even link to that in the
description if I think of it so if you
want to watch this you can this is a
story of a man named Alan he is he's he
works he has a wife he's got two sons
one who's getting ready to go to
university another a bit younger I
actually heard had a hard time
pinpointing the younger boys age because
there was how old he looked and how old
he acted and there was a slight
disconnect there but anyways and he Alan
the David Tennant character he gets run
over
he stops a very nasty accident I he's in
a coma for a bit
and when he comes out of it there is
some cognitive damage there's some brain
damage and the movie is is the recovery
the movie is going through the
difficulties that he's having the way it
impacts the people or
around him and how everybody either does
or doesn't cope with everything going on
so this isn't really the kind of movie
that I would normally gravitate to it it
feels a little overly harsh for me to
call it misery porn but that was kind of
where my head was at while watching it
this is a story about something awful
happens now watch how all these other
awful things are a result of it and
watch how things get harder and harder
and tougher and tougher and worse and
worse
and I'm not to say that I can't handle a
story that where things get
progressively worse I mean I enjoy the
occasional zombie story and they pretty
much follow that same format the
difference is there's an escapism to
something like 28 days later that this
doesn't have because this is very
grounded in reality so it really does
feel like I'm watching a family try and
deal with something that really nobody
can plan for and it's actually kind of
unreasonable to ask anybody to deal with
and I mean that both for for David
Tennant's character in terms of what he
has to go through to try and function as
an adult again and what his family has
to go through trying to help him get
there while also dealing with the fact
that he is emotionally unstable and he's
he's not connecting dots in the right
order anymore and he's potentially
dangerous like he you know you can't you
can't let him cook you can't let him use
a whole bunch of different things
because he doesn't remember how to use
things properly anymore and because
there is brain damage that's not just
like he doesn't remember it's not just
memory it is the cognitive function so
he has to relearn all this stuff from
scratch so it's not just a matter of oh
he doesn't remember I show him once and
then he's fine no he has to reconnect
that entire neural pathway so it's rough
watching at least it was for me because
something that feels this grounded in
this real and the
tension that builds up in certain
moments where a scene starts and you're
looking at the sarin just going oh god
oh god cuz you're seeing all the ways
that this setup could possibly go wrong
given what you know about the situation
and the characters dealing with it and
then you just have to sit and watch as
it goes wrong and sometimes it takes its
time doing that I suppose another thing
it reminds me of a bit it's a bit like a
cringe humor movie where there's no
jokes and it's difficult for me to watch
for the same reason you know one of if a
scene starts and I know what's going to
happen and I know it's going to be
embarrassing and humiliating and
degrading for the people involved
I don't enjoy sitting through that
whether it's for the purposes of comedy
liking currency more or more for the
purposes of drama like in misery porn so
this was not a particularly pleasant
viewing experience for me that doesn't
make it a bad movie I think it just has
everything to do with what you either
gravitate towards or can or can't handle
and it's certainly a good showcase for
David Tennant as an actor it's actually
all the actors do a very good job which
is part of what makes it so difficult
everybody is very naturalistic everybody
has a very fluid established rapport it
really does feel like you're watching
people who have known each other for
years and that's a testament to the
acting but then for the kinds of things
that make this thing hard for me to
watch it amps that up as well because it
makes it all the more real I think the
thing is I think the reason this hit me
harder and like was more difficult for
me to watch then like because like this
is the kind of story I tend to avoid but
on the few occasions that I've seen it
before
it's been stuff like on the Hallmark
Channel so it was it wasn't well acted
it wasn't well written it wasn't well
shot and so it didn't impact me the way
this does because I could kind of laugh
it off be like oh god this is stupid
but I couldn't with this because it's
convincingly it seemed I have no
first-hand experience in anything like
this but from my limited experience
perspective it felt very real it felt
like from a writing standpoint whoever
wrote the script had done the legwork to
try and come across in the scene
structure and the dialogue how something
like this would actually pan out it is
as I said very well acted it is very
well shot the camera oftentimes gets
intimate with the characters in a way
that is kind of voyeuristic you you know
it just David Tennant steps into a
shower and you know the camera is just
in there with him with just these sort
of very naturalistic shakes and you know
this handheld feel but usually when you
say somebody shot handheld you're
thinking like it's jittery like that
like no it's just sort of this natural
ebb and flow like you would have if you
were standing in the space and just sort
of standing steadying yourself and in
that way it kind of feels almost
documentary style and almost invasive
which again adds to the effect of what
it's doing but also adds to the effect
of what made me uncomfortable watching
it so it's absolutely effective in what
it is doing it's just one of those
situations where for me what it's doing
is something that makes me uncomfortable
to watch but I can still recognize the
skill and the talent that went into it
on pretty much every level I don't I
didn't look into the production history
I don't know if this was like a BBC TV
production or what this is but it didn't
it looked like it was probably
low-budget I didn't recognize anybody
other than David Tennant but whatever it
was they worked well within their means
and they put together of a
well-constructed piece of work just not
it's not in the genre I would normally
go for but see that I mean that's that's
part of what the patreon Commission's
are
four people can if they want get me to
step out of my comfort zone and
sometimes that results in something well
oftentimes that results in something I
never will watched otherwise and
sometimes that's a really eye-opening
experience and other times that's a oh
boy yeah okay I'm gonna go we're gonna
go do some comfort food viewing
I'm gonna catch up a little bit more on
the West Wing that's what I'm gonna do
now that's my current comfort food
watching Liz got me into it and the fact
that I've now tangent Adana that
probably means I've said everything that
I have to say about this as much as I
said that you know it made me
uncomfortable to watch I don't I really
hope that the person who commissioned me
isn't like oh god I feel bad that like
don't it's good for me to feel
uncomfortable about these things
sometimes it is helpful for me to have
those experiences to remind myself of
how I respond to things because if you
just avoid something that you don't like
forever you you lose the thread of what
the issue is and why you process the way
that you do and I think there's some
degree of good to be done just sort of
being reminded every now and then yeah
this thing that that you're not
comfortable with have you thought about
it lately
have you thought about why that's the
case is that still the case I mean
there's some yeah I'm not upset that I
got Commission to review this I I find
some value out of watching it I won't
watch it again but not because it's not
good just because what it is is not for
me but yeah that's it that's it it's
March it's my birthday month I've got a
link for my Amazon wish list down the
description although if you really want
to give me a little bit present I would
recommend you consider supporting me on
patreon in any amount it is helpful in
the rewards and I won't do the full
pitch now because I am tired and beat
whatever like subscribe you know the
things but you don't have to do them
either even though I'm sick like I'm not
trying to play the sympathy card here
cuz you're the council I'm just running
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]